you have tattoos everywhere no I mean I
have a chest tattoo I have a Koreatown
tattooed across my let me say look how
you see it real quick
Kelly when I was young yeah oh that's
dog you know what it wasn't note when I
first got it cuz it was literally my
first tattoo just the font of Koreatown
yeah and then you got all the stray yeah
but it's like for like a couple a couple
years I had nothing but a town right so
thank you were sponsored by them exactly
I go to water parks you know I don't
know it worked out later like it's weird
cuz now thinking back is even got a rep
k-town like I don't want it Nestle
ta-da'-da girl does that mean just you
know representing my community you know
what I'm saying up career so here's the
thing yeah you represent Koreatown
gimme get can you can it rattled me five
restaurants there in your top five okay
we'll start with will have categories so
let's just basic Korean barbecue so
let's I'm gonna go barbecue so barbecue
because I want to eat there if I it's
not on my list I've been out the
barbecue game for a little bit you know
what I'm saying I'll admit that
oh so give me give me your top three in
your barbecue top three Korean barbecue
I wonder if he'll say no Louisiana
[ __ ] rib riblets weird
yeah Korean barbecue Jasper Kim's gonna
get um see uh what for pork maybe Gupta
ji oh honey pig honey pig and pie SEC
whichever that really I don't think I've
ever been to honey pig or cows or head
yeongchun head John that's all you can
you got that the diameter but there's
also guy diarrhea there there's also the
new spots you know like quarters like
the white people spot
and the only reason is the white
people's but because it's called
quarters and not like some Koreans yeah
and then in that little castle area
there's one across the end there what's
up
and that's fairly new to that's only
like the last two three but you don't
eat we just had a choice on that was
chosen is like the the bougie BBQ very
good big menu so you can take people who
don't you know they you know you got
parks barbecue that's like it's so good
it's so delicious
what about that one that fell off how
does she know Oh super super busy spot
that's like since I was three years old
yeah I used to bring my parents are they
still around yeah they're still around
you know the shot I went there I went
though with you know uh Roy Choi the
chef yeah and add Giada yeah so Giada
shot an episode and invited Roy and Roy
invited me and we did a whole thing that
was tight she's related to Oscar de la
Renta I don't know that is but I know
she's a MILF he's not Food Network
another thing that's big in Koreatown is
chicken places the chicken wings stuff
like that right yeah you have a deal one
Pro I don't really know I I know there's
last book I just see it on my post mates
and I just kind of go for one yeah yeah
they have that one right by sick street
I got John yeah
cochon bb2 chicken BBG chicken but then
there's also a place like OB bear what's
that you never been over there uh it's
more like kind of like splotched us but
what is that kind of chicken and it's
like really good OB bear I like I'm ham
g-park hungry pop rock for pork ribs
that's the red stew not listening that
don't live in LA
sorry don't give a [ __ ] about Korean
food I'm sorry sorry man this is gotta
be this is hard for people to spell out
like phonetically you know what I'm
saying why that's why like I feel like
hoarders is doing well just because a
quarter I know that is Baek Jong across
the street is kang ho-dong Baek Jo yeah
right what yeah when people ask me like
the spots I say quarters cuz I don't
want to spell out [ __ ] really do it out
of laziness and that's why I like this
world some of the Korean business are
[ __ ] up cuz oh you should just name
it Dave
you don't know Dave
Korean barbecue it's really good that's
why I think parks is winning too because
it's hard it's easy as Laurie just parks
barbecue yeah that's interesting I
really thought about I really think
that's the reason
parks is like winning you know that you
and I could but you think we you and I
can open a barbecue restaurant and have
a kill it call Parker yeah we do we got
a lie close at 2:00 in the morning
that'd be the slogan like we got the
best Korean barbecue it's actually a
great name for a barbecue spot yeah
Beck's Korean barbecue CT no no not the
x-y I like facts will argue about that
during the poor so my dad's like my dad
had this business in downtown like you
know wholesale business and it was like
parks trading company but it was
supposed to be like pucks you know that
Koreans pronounced in pots yeah so he
spells it PA X always thought it like
that yeah and I was wondering like why
do you have it packs and he's like all
his pucks I was like oh it's cool though
parks is Angelina Jolie's kid right they
smell like that
[Music]